dr. Pomerance forget the ruble and
Ukraine for just a second what is the
state right now of the actual Russian
economy well the Russian economy is
poised to fall at least 3 to 5 percent
according to experts but it could be
even worse there have been various
attempts to rally around the banking and
convert and financial sectors but as you
mentioned mainstream Russia is about to
feel this recession very deeply and it's
going to last at least a year if not
longer is any of this fixable you
pointed out in an article recently that
small companies are 22 percent of the
Russian economy that number for the US
economy is 48 percent can any of that be
fixed over this small short or even
medium term no it can't there has been
various attempts by President Putin at
least in his recent speeches to support
the small and medium-sized enterprises
in Russia unfortunately that is the
sector that is most compromised and is
most subject to corruption and if you
can't eliminate the corruption that
surrounds the small and medium-sized
enterprises then they're not going to
grow throw the fact that interest rates
are still at 15% and they can't get any
credit and no small business is not
going to be the engine of growth in
Russia bill I love your note saying that
Vladimir Putin is offering Main Street
bread and vodka to weather the crisis
will that work it could work in the
short term clearly he's trying to make
sure that the staples of the Russian
economy and by that I'm referring to
bread wheat and the price of vodka
remains low so that the level of
dissatisfaction doesn't rise there been
yet more attempts this weekend to make
sure that the price of vodka remains low
again this is really addressing the the
symptoms of the problem it's not
addressing the underlying problems and
it won't it can keep people happy for a
while but if the economy continues to
tumble other manifestations will evolve
dr. Pomerantz you sum this up kind of
elegantly in an article you wrote
recently you actually said this is vodka
no max Putin knows that hi vodka prices
invariable correlate to low public
opinion ratings but he's got a different
group of people to please right now he
she has to make his oleg arts happy who
were worried about the real Russian
economy
he has a lot of different constituencies
that he has to keep happy including the
oligarchs the major state enterprises
and the Russian population and doing so
is very difficult in light of the
current economic crisis Putin's
popularity was always based on the fact
that during his first two terms he
produced really an economic miracle with
strong economic growth that's not going
to happen this time around he has to
find an alternative and it's been
nationalism and it's been the Imperial
card dr. Palmer's Nicholas Taleb just
out moments ago on Twitter quoting
history seen backwards does not equal
history lived forwards when Vladimir
Putin looks backwards what does he look
- well Vladimir Putin essentially is
cherry-picking different parts of
Russian history and trying to take them
up-to-date and the problem with that is
that the Soviet experience was so severe
and so strong that you really can't go
back and pick out eighteenth-century
maps which Putin has done and some of
them somehow applied them to the 21st
century time has moved on and Putin's
attempt to kind of pick the parts of
Russian history that he wants to support
his his current activities really
doesn't work because there was such a
major break in Russian history during
the Soviet period dr. Pomerantz just
quickly from the Russian perspective you
know a lot of people could say that NATO
right now is lining up command centers
across the Eastern Front and that looks
pretty aggressive how does this play out
in Moscow well I think Putin has already
accused NATO of being in Ukraine and
orchestrating the response to the
current offensive by the rebels so I
think Putin will continue to blame NATO
to say that NATO is more engaged than it
really is
but at the same time we're looking at
the NATO reconsidering how it deals with
Ukraine alright bill thank you so much
bill Pomerance joining us there from the
Kenan Institute
appreciate your time